facciamo gli studenti oggi qui per fare
esperimento sul magnetismo che oggi
inservienti che volere bene adottare e
quindi far vedere nella intro del video
come funzionare magnetismo professore
totalmente d'accordo con questo metodo
di video carpet grazie dottore che altro
tutta magnetica per dimostrare funzioni
di magnetismo diamo il via all'esame
oggi totò e tra una calamita e l'altra
fare esperimento molto molto carino ma
allo stesso tempo molto pericoloso voi
non imitare casa essere veramente
telefono non utilizzare pezzo e
disturbante che totò hai preso e
tagliato che è fatto uscire questa
polverina chiamata pone quando tu prendi
quella polverina elaborate rotone li
iosco eleonora che più indicate questi
geni toner ha citato la cia fa
l'esperimento mentre calamite si
attaccano al tavolo con il magnetismo es
pavimento con magnetismo funzionari
piante l'utilizzo di questo pezzo di
stampanti che tutt ora è staccato dalla
sostanza in chiamato toner come dottore
dal motore uscire polverina di torrent
che che sarebbe la poverina di un
chiostro della stampante voi non usare
questa polverina non fare il riferimento
a casa perché molto pericoloso dov è
molto serio
oggi totò e far diventare questo toccò a
liquido e utilizzare liquido magnetico
vedere carcere innanzitutto torres
mettere questo perché sennò ti toglie un
po ipocondriaco quindi preservare salute
di totò vero generazioni future come si
metterà questo sapendo dottore c'era
nobilitati il sapiente e con sapiente a
mano ricordiamo come si dice candele il
pep come esperimento di primo episodio
musica però è che mi da fare adesso
passa a esaurimento dei posti
meglio ha lanciato la quasi mettere cia
tra l'altro in inchiostro fa soffre e
versare circa pochettino di te
l'inchiostro di areva danceability per
cortesia che dopo averlo un po paura
dottore versare 3 cucchiai di olio di
semi vari quello di seminare il seme di
quercia semeraro per save dentro
cucchiaio dai problemi ad aprire olio di
semi
olio di semi dito torre versare dentro
cucchiaio circa 3 cucchiai se non euro
uno dei prezzi un pochettino abbiamo
andare dove adesso girare aperto così
polverina raggirata prima diventare il
liquido liquido che dovrei usare per
cercare magnetismo casina sta facendo il
dottore versare liquido su piattaforma
costruita appositamente per l'acciaio
inox perfetto dove disegnare paperina 90
fatto e adesso fa bene anche a tokyio
magnetico perché se noi utilizza
calamità presa da tende della norma non
è uno scherzo della compreso da
attendere magari troviamo queste che
ormai carico lo scampato
se noi utilizza calamità sotto
plasticone liquido muoversi
[Applauso]
liquido magnetico di dottore effetto
incredibile
questi effetti speciali utilizzati anche
nei film tipo be non ho anche in
videogiochi tipo tex training se noi
rimanere fermi crearsi cunetta se noi
muoversi
si colloca la vita
[Musica]
in crediti portato a nient'altro creato
un albero motore artista esperimento
funzionale perché chiudo da che fluido
magnetico rimanere costante il summit
come che funzionale fermo nella sostanza
possibilità dalle nanoparticelle
magnetiche sospesi in un vicolo fluido
come acqua e olio per fluido è una
sostanza costituita da nanoparticelle
mano come il signore degli anelli però
magnetiche che sospese in un veicolo
fluido come acqua olio il ferro fluido
non è che romagn etico ovviamente ovvero
continua a non essere magnetizzato anche
dopo che il campo magnetico viene
allevato motivo per cui è definito
magnetico mi raccomando state attenti
perché togliere non andare via da
vestiti o cose e se inalato molto
pericoloso soprattutto se qualcuno di
ambienti e sassi macchiato controller
essere un casino perché totale dover
cambiare tutto gli esami
spero che esperimento conto neanche si
sa che giustamente dover apprendere
pezzo perché necessità viene infatti per
confusione video grazie ambienti molto
giù di lì
ferentino gravi nel prendere le cose noi
e ci si veda dunque assieme episodio di
sperone di incredibile tra due settimane
dopo aver capito
[Musica]